I had a comic buddy come on and he's
he's been doing it for a while right and
listen he's funny but he hasn't made a
new set in [ __ ] 10 years yeah you got
those guys exactly right and so he comes
on the podcast and he's just kind of
griping about like other comics about
making excuses why he didn't make it and
I'm like dog nobody wants to hear this
on a podcast nobody wants to hear about
you [ __ ] on other comments a Debbie
Downer yeah exactly nobody wants to hear
about why you you couldn't do things
because of this because of your family
because you have kids I was like at the
end of the day dude this was an
opportunity for you to come on here and
do something and you [ __ ] blew it
again in five four three two one what's
up everybody welcome to another episode
of The Genius brain podcast yeah we got
some special guests here apparently I'm
the only [ __ ] Asian here yeah this is
a [ __ ] Latin X that's right welcome
to L.A bro
[Music]
this one knows all the Mexican joints
I've been to so many because of him I
don't even know [ __ ] out here when he
starts talking he's like oh my God I'm
like the Asian Taco King in L.A because
like so in in your private fraud is like
this foodie [ __ ] right people never ever
got Mexican food in UCLA because people
are just scared to go there but that's
where all the food is you have to go
there so it's funny because me and my
buddy Vince
we're both Asian dudes but we love
eating at like authentic spots just
because it just tastes better you know
what I mean but nobody would come
through so there's a spot uh Avenue 26
that I used to go to I blew them the
[ __ ] up so people slightly hated me
because I did a video for them and then
after that just people started flooding
there but then at the same time it's
like a funny story behind that it's like
I used to go there so often that uh the
guy Caesar who owns the spot he would
like hook me up with free tacos and I
was like oh there's other you know who I
am he goes nah you just eat her I'm like
man I'm [ __ ] fat dude
that was a fat asian guy that would eat
there every night yeah bro that was a
humbling moment that was a little [ __ ]
up that was it used to lay right there
right yeah after the Dodger games that's
like a known spot everybody just goes oh
really I've never been to that one it's
really good though yeah
that's like a barbecue spot yeah it's
like a regular like uh chain right it's
like a little chain I mean
[Laughter]
I don't remember just like every every
time you kick with Mexican homies there
was always like a sibling that gave a
[ __ ] up nickname to all the time
everybody had a nickname like I thought
this one Fool's name was like [ __ ]
Gordo his whole life
what's your real name it's like dude
it's Jose I'm like I thought your name
was Gordo right I said what does that
means
it happened to me when I worked at
Burger King my the manager signed with I
always call them Gordo but I'm like
whitewashed Hispanic yeah cause I don't
know any Spanish with that blonde hair
now dude
like a construction worker rocking that
haircut
and then one day the guy the guy that I
worked with Irving he was like you know
what that means right I was like nah
he's like it means fat yeah I was like
so every time I say I'm like hey what's
so fat
yeah I was like damn that's weird
in my stand-up that I call my my dad
calls this uh is a uh cousin Cumbia and
Kumbia has a Latin dance so he calls on
that because he was born with a crooked
hips yeah it looks like he's dancing for
life I was like I thought it was just
normal cool man yeah and I'm like
[ __ ] name is George and we're over
here
yeah
it was so funny came to the States was
and some lady was reversing a car at
Walmart bumped into him and she got off
and he started walking it's okay and
it's like oh my God
foreign
[Laughter]
people over and over yeah but yeah Alex
has been talking to you to me about you
for a while yeah me and this guy go back
dude a long time right when I was like
sorry I got my first tour yeah
yeah
dude hey what's up bro
talk about Yankee promoters
to ask you about this guy named Gotti at
some kind of Latin yeah dude explain
this story yeah yeah so this guy is the
most Yankees promoter and you know what
I mean one of those guys that's got like
that a lot a lot of jewelry is like why
why so much jewelry just [ __ ] just
the name alone that's her name no stop
forcing this this you know he was a
rapper too he was like a Latino but he
liked the like uh Italian aspect of it
and he was a showman he was like oh
we're gonna do this and we're gonna put
these lights and we're gonna say this
and it's like bro just just it was this
comedy show he always host the shows too
he was always had to be the host of the
show this guy sounds like me okay
nervous before he goes up I'm like he's
just bringing me up bro
oh man I'm nervous man why are you even
going up are you the promoter and [ __ ]
dude that guy he was that guy that's
just like oh just no we didn't get
enough money today I don't think so back
to house everybody what do you mean he
just like he's just janky dude
everything was janky like certain people
got flights and some people had to ride
in his truck bro
you got to do like a [ __ ] 10 hour
drive to [ __ ] Clovis New Mexico
why I don't
he flew one person into Las Cruces so we
go from Arizona we pick up him from Las
Cruces so he was the only one who got to
fly yeah and then we had to drive back
and it was just and it was it was yeah
it's just like what's going on right now
right so what is y'all's gorgeous story
I guess I I met him because he had a
camera dude he was following him around
I'm like so he was documented because he
was just one of those like yo this is
hot yeah all the time yeah I met him so
I used to work at Best Buy and this pool
comes in this pool comes into the
computer section right and he's like
trying to get some to edit some [ __ ]
because he was filming these these tours
and he was asking oh do you know how to
do this by chance I was like yeah I make
music videos and [ __ ] so then he was
like Hey if you're down meet me on my
spot afterwards I got like a business
proposition for you so it was me and my
homie Patrick who you yeah Patrick who's
not a comic yeah yeah and uh so we went
to his house and he's like I got this
tour man it's gonna be the next big
thing it's the next Latin toy yeah
everything was the next big state yeah
he's one of those guys and so he started
showing me and I'm like all right and
he's like I'll pay you guys I just need
you guys to come film them some shows
like I edit it's like all right whatever
cool so I used to go to the shows but
the first time I'm at Jesus we came out
here maybe like 10 years ago at John
Lovett's theater yeah
CityWalk yeah it was ham there's a
couple other people I think if I
remember some names like Luke Torres uh
I got I forget his name the guy that
does like the belly
uh [ __ ] he's gonna get Maddox
but we all know yeah the red shirt with
the belly
um
I remember the other guy's like
trademark was like subway yeah yeah I
was gonna say Rodriguez but I want to be
wrong and be happy
that I walked in in the hotel room they
wanted me introduce me to the guy he had
like a shirt off he was changing this
was like cameras is important
these those are all just like behind
them they're recording and [ __ ] and then
I did my setting afterwards he was like
yo that [ __ ] was cool from Arizona I'm
from Tucson so we just hit it off and
then at the tour we were just like you
know
we were just looking at how Wild
everybody was acting yeah it was weird
but yeah and Jerry too Jerry did one
Jerry did a lot of the tours too yeah it
was funny how he would like [ __ ] uh
link up with like you know the group is
interesting yeah you know I'm just I'm
out here yeah we got a meeting with
Netflix you know we gotta get back
there's still people like that but I
remember just you know back in the day
everybody would just talk such a big
game and there was no way to verify that
[ __ ] especially because you know when
you're super green on the scene you
didn't believe anything yeah people back
then could have told me anything I would
have believed him yeah yeah but hey man
so I know the the [ __ ] executive yeah
HBO I'm like what oh so you want me to
get you a drink or something yeah yeah
so you know we're trying to get our come
up and so every time somebody would say
[ __ ] like that we would you know we'd
get excited yeah then you started
learning small things here and there
it's like wait a second like what the
[ __ ] you why would you even tell me that
[ __ ] because people who make big moves
they don't talk like they can bro I went
to it
secretly I went to a uh uh this was like
early on like hella green out here yo
like I moved out here 19 so it's like
1920 or 21 whatever but I was like uh
trying to get into a uh like modeling
agency right
it was in a studio building uh uh and I
go into his office and it was uh you
could tell like it kind of it smelled
like he lives in his office oh yeah it
was like he had he had a he had a back
like a a door entrance of like uh but it
was like the beads it was like that's
how he was like covering that was funny
and I'm like okay that was already all
right
yeah
it's called luxury agency it's like no
one causing some luxury anything with
luxury on it sucks bro yeah straight up
yeah and then he was showing like um
like uh like his portfolio like he had
like the like pictures that were like he
was that he blew up that show like who
he who he was around right he's in the
background yeah
he's going the other way
but he was showing all these like I work
with these people I work with these
people instead I take pictures I'm like
wow like and that was really just kind
of like it I I was so naive I'm like
damn this guy's worked with a lot of
people bro I mean it yeah I had the same
thing with the i i an agency because
this guy's like he saw me at shows like
he wants you to come down and audition
and I want to be an agent and I was like
cool he's going to be my agent so I go
over there dude this I knew I like he
was not great first of all the same
thing with the bees he had a cat running
around and I'm all right I learned some
lines I came back right he had a
computer dude that was messy with like
the computers from the 90s you know what
I mean one of those old-school Macintosh
anyways uh I thought he was like working
he was playing Solitaire fool he was
just like I was learning lines outside
in the lobby and then I come back in and
I I I mess it all up I do it all wrong
and at the end it goes I'm literally
butchering everything the lines I suck
and he's just like all right so what
I'll do I'll sign you for a year and
then I'm like no I know you but if I
sucked and you still want to sign me
something's up you have no clients so
yeah you start learning these like
bougie ass agents and stuff yeah once
they like they're they're talking money
up front then it ain't it ain't real
yeah 100 I want to start wanting to do
contracts for a year you're like when
did you come to L.A I came 2009 I was 19
when I first came oh 2009 dude what was
it like when you first came here like a
thousand dollars it was [ __ ] dude it
was scary I was uh just thinking about
this like dude I remember when I first
got here I like wanted to cry I was the
first feeling I had because I was from a
small town and I kept doing like I don't
need a small town I'm ready to go
already I was ready to leave leave my
family behind everybody right yeah then
when I get to the freeways and on I feel
so small and you have no one to talk to
and no one's around and then for some
reason when the day like when it turned
into night that's when I just felt like
alone and I was like and I went to like
that house that I was like renting at
and I was at that couch I remember going
like oh [ __ ] I'm alone yeah I never felt
like that I always had a family this
time it was like if something happens
right now no one my dad's eight hours
away he can't get here yeah I'm alone I
gotta figure this [ __ ] out yeah and I
just felt like vulnerable and wanted to
cry but I was like oh [ __ ] that I need
to like yeah
whenever I get a moment of vulnerability
they start jacking off
that's like toxic women you know what I
mean that violence turned me on you know
but yeah dude and I just you know I had
to snap out of me you had to just you
know toughen up yeah so you came here
straight just to just stand just do
stand-up dude what was your first show
here it was at the Laugh Factory I did
the open mic because I in my mind I'm
like yo I'm just gonna go blow up and
then go back home what am I doing all
right two days because I signed up to
open mic dude I saw I remember uh uh
Eddie Griffin was outside uh parked and
he was like he got like a check or
something he just walked in and he's
like all right good luck everybody and
he just jumped that's my Eddie Griffin
it's so racist
[Laughter]
hello everybody
[Laughter]
just always the coolest people in the
world
uh her uh gender reveal at the uh like
uh you know the baby gender review or
whatever right and so like uh the father
uh he's black and the whole the family
was there too and I don't know why I
just kept saying like oh a lot yeah [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Black Culture is pop culture it's
everything that's cool so it's like
every time somebody sees like black
people like I I used to hate this [ __ ]
because I used to do it a lot too but
the thing is it was the opposite for me
because I grew up you know all my
friends were black yeah group went to a
black church [ __ ] so I had a code
switch the other way around and then I
didn't realize too and I wish I didn't
do this so much now because now I got
rid of most of it was because when I was
trying to get jobs you could tell people
to treat you a certain way if you spoke
a certain way yeah and I didn't realize
that I had like what quote unquote
people call the black accent until I
recorded myself and I'm like who the
[ __ ] is that
who the [ __ ] is talking right now I'm
like like that's you so you don't want
to hire me because the way that I speak
so I remember I used to go home and I
used to record myself talking just to
kind of like undo certain things that I
would say hello everybody
yeah you know what my theory was is like
that you know black people like black
entertainers were the voice for us a
hundred percent for us anybody that was
colored like they wrote a voice for us
because we didn't have us on TV but they
were speaking for us like I spotted like
like not having opportunities talking
[ __ ] making fun of the white guys like
they were doing that for we had nobody
so we grew up with their music grow up
with their shows grow with Martin like
we didn't have anybody to look up to so
we felt like you know we were a little
black we were just like we were part of
Black Culture too because we just saw it
we grew up with it you know that's why
too like interesting you mentioned that
because there was that whole change uh I
think it was probably when I was a
freshman in uh College where depending
on where you grew up because Northern
California was super loose with the
n-word right oh yeah everybody could see
it and that's the thing that a lot of
young people don't understand like times
have changed now for sure but when you
talk to somebody who's in their 40s and
they're you know they it slips out of
them mouth is because they grew up in a
different time it's widely accepted you
can even see interviews of Like Rappers
talking about the word they'll ask why
do you say it so much or do you care if
somebody there's an interview yeah he
was like saying like no like if you say
it like this then I'm cool with it
whatever yeah so times have changed so
much yeah I mean like dude like when
we're in the in the 90s like they would
you know my neighborhood they would be
we were using everybody was around we
were just like the way we were sick
because we were around each other so
much yeah it just was like in that
moment it was like okay it wasn't okay
but it's just it's like whoever was a
part of like the black community that
allowed you to use it they put you in
the community I think that's what like
black people do so well is that when
they [ __ ] with you they [ __ ] with you
heavily yeah yeah and so they do this
like circle of acceptance a lot of
people didn't realize that passport
doesn't go everywhere that's right
especially those black shows if you
don't if you don't got it
I would do the family room right here in
Compton just look at me just like
old songs back in the day and back in
Arizona because you so he was in Tucson
I was in South Phoenix so we were kind
of far from each other but I grew up
with a lot of blacks and Hispanics and
essays right so that's all he did but I
listened to my old rap songs I'm like oh
yeah
go check out this new track I'm like bro
if you don't get children
it was bad but it's true but I think we
do a good job turning it on and off I
think as I got older like I can like
when I'm around my old homies back in uh
in Phoenix or you know even when me and
David kind of get back because we kind
of grew up like yeah we could talk that
way but then when it's like supposed to
be normal
it's hard because minorities we know
when to yeah that's the thing and we can
feel the vibe have you ever had a friend
like so I have a friend who uh who went
to the military when he was 18 right and
like a lot of friends who go into the
military it's a time capsule so who they
were when they were 18 that's who they
are and they do all the military [ __ ] so
I remember a buddy of mine he just got
out and he was visiting me out in K-Town
and he forgot time to change this
[ __ ] well he caught up his
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
it comes out
and right when he's here for him he goes
what's up I'm like hey oh yeah and I'm
mortified I'm like looking at him what's
going on my wife is next to me and she's
like who's this guy and I was like uh
that's my friend she goes I don't like
him man we're home goods right now we're
in Target right now bombs like crazy and
I'm sitting here just like hey man uh
tone that down a little bit you don't
say no more
but you know he was in that time capsule
so he still does one doctor yeah but
also too like
he looks black ah he looks so if he said
it nobody would say anything otherwise
I'm like I'm as goofy as a guess
he's like a crystal so Crystal's a get
away with a lot yeah I see him get away
with a lot yeah I've seen him on stage
saying like it's hard for us black
people and I'm just like Christmas
I'm Puerto Rican and Dominican you know
you got it in here what I say is we just
had a different stop on the boat you
don't say they stopped by our Island
then they went to you know what I mean
this is all it is
yeah yeah so you know it's just there's
a little history in there I don't I
don't go too heavy on it but I know I
know what's up that's crazy you know we
have the car I don't I don't got that at
all yeah
and honestly like I didn't even I didn't
really understand that like because back
I'm from Houston you know like when my
upbringing was like a lot of Mexican
black people and you know for white
people as well but it was all right and
uh that was the same thing you know like
I was hearing all over the place and you
know and and nice like you said too
people didn't really know what to take
me at like I look black you know what
I'm saying and I have that uh like
appearance and stuff but
um I was just I was rocking with who's
rocking with me and I was black folks
yeah I was like my like my black homies
and black girlfriends you know I mean
majority of my girlfriends have been
black actually 90 of them yeah I'm
saying but it's just what I like that
that's that's what I said I could
literally remember the first time I ever
used the word was like so outside of my
parents store my parents on a black
beauty supply store so there's this dude
like there's always that old head in the
neighborhood that kicks it all the time
and so in front of my parents store
every Friday there was a food truck
called Moe's so Moe's would sell Philly
cheesesteak tacos whatever the [ __ ] it
was and every Thursday Friday and
Saturday they would like throw a block
party in front of my parents store in
that parking lot people be shooting dice
they'd be doing whatever the [ __ ] it is
right yeah so I'm over here as a little
kid shooting dice with these old heads
but I remember too like I told the story
before where I remember this guy you
know this old head that was always there
he took me aside he was like hey what's
up because you know you know what you
call me I'm like no I don't know what to
call you he goes you say that I'm your
right and I'm like oh what is that he
goes like Oh when you when you cool with
us you always have to come you say that
what do you say to me you said I'm your
what and from that point on I just
started using the words so often yeah
and you know everybody got a kick out of
it but that's like it was that weird
moment of acceptance I felt really
accepted it was like maybe eight or nine
years old but at that point it was just
I kept using the word because they loved
it they accepted me as a part of that
Circle right yeah so it was just such a
weird thing and I just remember going to
college and when that didn't apply in
this small neighborhood they're like hey
man why are you using that word I was
like
what's your problem
everybody was so confusing I didn't
realize that Southern California it was
never like that in Northern California
because it's so like culturally diverse
and mixed SoCal is not mixed you have a
lot of different culture [ __ ] but
there's you know Mexicans kick it over
here Black Folk kick it over here you go
to Diamond Bar
I used to live in Danville where am I
and in Sacramento everybody kind of
intermingles so so where did you grow up
at Sacramento California oh yeah so I
moved to LA about 12 years ago oh okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it was like a big
learning curve for me and after a while
I was just like I don't care about the
word enough to use it so it's like it'll
slip out here and there because of
obviously 20 years of habit and but most
of the time it's just like I don't care
I broke into it softly I was saying it
in middle school but I was saying uh
Nick like a like the boy Nick Nick
confusing
it's weird now like when we when I talk
I have to censor myself a little bit and
that's the only weird thing about where
we're at nowadays yeah sometimes when I
say something I don't I can't be so
direct like I used to I had to catch
myself like dude I'm still struggling
with the f word dude
because when we grew up
yeah in school
a bad way like but it's like to me it's
like yo who are you to say the way you
think I'm saying it like I'm not saying
it the way you think I'm saying you're
the one that's thinking that yeah but
then it's like who's gonna it's a weird
way to defend myself yeah it's such a
weird thing because like how we
interpreted back in the day now is just
I just go with times like if people are
uncomfortable with it then it makes
sense and I always go with the people
that it affects the most so it affects
you like that it's not my career it's
your community and if it [ __ ] you up so
much in the head I could just take it
out yeah you know like things change all
the time like but don't you think it
feels weird knowing that they're
controlling how you are around your
circle so now they control your circles
they're like wow to be around my friends
like and people might agree or disagree
with this I always say this is like be
mindful about how you say things to
people you don't know there you go and
then how you say things around their
kids because that's not in your place so
if they're uncomfortable with it be very
[ __ ] mindfulness and don't be an
[ __ ] yeah with whatever happens
within your circle as long as you don't
put it out there like that I say do
whatever that's your life that's your
business I don't give a [ __ ] yeah I like
that I like that so somebody's like yeah
he was like man around my you know like
black friends or whatever whatnot I
don't give [ __ ] yeah but as long as you
ain't walking around [ __ ] you know
like especially when they're with you
and they're just like going all crazy
that would be the weird thing I remember
uh
when I first started doing YouTube I was
doing these shows right and because of
the way that I would speak I remember
like it was specifically at the show and
there was this kid that asked this Asian
kid goes hey like you know I'm like you
I kind of grew up around a lot of black
people and like I feel like I should say
you know do you really care when people
say the N word and I was like you racist
bro yeah
the kid I was like why are you so
impressed about it because well I grew
up saying and I was like but it doesn't
affect you so if you say it and somebody
doesn't say it like you can go to sleep
at night feeling fine like if somebody
grew up around that word where it made
them feel like [ __ ] and lesser than like
where somebody was literally racially
abusing them yeah and that's how people
feel this is the culture that's not your
own I was like think about it like this
like what if like you're Asian and
somebody said well I grew up uh when the
sun was really bright everybody would
just do this but that was just us
because we didn't have sunglasses but so
he would just walk around do this yeah
but it makes you feel a certain way it
wouldn't change the fact how you feel
about that because of how it made you
feel and how made a majority of Asian
people feel yeah so that's true man yeah
so when you think about it like that and
you're only thinking about your purse
personal instance is not really a place
for you to say so let let the culture
decide what the [ __ ] it is so they feel
a certain way and if even within the
culture they haven't made up their mind
well that's their business no but I just
not say it then yeah you could just stay
out of trouble and then if you say it
every now and then within your group of
friends that accept it and allow it then
why the [ __ ] not just be careful about
what you do outside and the [ __ ] that
you put out there you know yeah I agree
man the whole like Iceland thing and
stuff that was my first bid in
kindergarten so yeah
well you know I'm a church kid right so
I'm a church kid so I wasn't used
oh [ __ ] we used to go to uh I just can't
figure yo this [ __ ] right here
mission trips right and the first place
that you usually go for mission trips is
like Tijuana and so when we were there
oh yeah those Latino kids no let me tell
you something man
folks that are in like Mexican culture
you would just walk around
[Laughter]
my uncle
[Applause]
and they would always put up the best
front as if they're like the closest to
God but they really were just trying to
get some dick I like that and the more
that you would you would pretend that
you were as holy as possible
no but that's why like people always
like Catholic girls oh yeah because they
would they would have to put up this
front so much that when at high school
they weren't the Catholic girl they
wanted to do [ __ ] that their parents
wouldn't allow they would repress them
so much for people to always like [ __ ]
around with them so much bro I had a oh
dude I had this [ __ ] girl that was a
Catholic girl and she invite me to her
house and she was a full rig like that
was I was I was like damn [ __ ] relax
like [ __ ] let's take it slow because
we'll be in the living room and her mom
is like we gotta do it so fast so God
doesn't see it yeah
dude her mama said don't see don't hurt
man that was her lifestyle bro she's a
tatted on her chest bro cause her mom
was right there fixing us like a dinner
and stuff and it was one of those like
uh living rooms where like the kitchen's
right here and it's open space but it's
like down in the living room right so I
can see her mom I just gotta speak up
and
I'm just finger banging her while her
mom is cooking something I'm just kind
of like no you're going to hell dude I
know it was like man this is some crazy
[ __ ] and she wanted that and I'm like
this is some crazy but I'm not stopping
because I'm here
I feel so like guilty but at the same
time it was like hey man you know I want
to we're here but in my mind I'm like
hey what happens happens dog you know
what I mean hey [ __ ] right even
though the crucifixion he was like
looking away like yeah
[Laughter]
that was a freaky ass chick I'm like God
damn but what I'm trying to say is like
she was all spiritual and she had her
mom how was she how did how did that and
how did she handle that like how was she
like was she staying like watching it or
was she really like in it she had the
pillow and she'll bite it and I'm like
oh my God
[Laughter]
so I was talking to a couple of friends
about this too but
um the other night I've never done
dating apps but oh because well by the
time like dating apps were really
popping I was I'm with the woman that I
married now so I never had that
opportunity but also too I would just go
with you out here
[Laughter]
dating apps I never got to do but I
always wanted to try but a lot of people
have been telling me like dating apps
are kind of weird because a lot of them
are scammers now so it'll be like some
hot chick or whatever she goes no just
you know follow me on Instagram I don't
like doing these dating apps
but they got only fans so they want you
to follow them oh yeah they do the same
thing on Snapchat oh you got Snapchat
all right best Snapchat was about to get
nasty I logged into my Snapchat for the
first time in like two years and I have
all these DMS and I'm like who the [ __ ]
are these yeah every single one was like
a link yeah
I know 100 in I'm like wait a minute
[Laughter]
yeah
they can get nasty I had a friend that
got set up on Twitter and everything
since then I was like ah now I'm never
doing Twitter yeah
back in the day before all the dating
app stuff it was always Instagram DMS or
like Twitter DMS or whatever the
original yeah
so yeah we could literally do this [ __ ]
where before we would go to a city I
would always
I mean I would put out that hey I'm
coming to your city right that wasn't
really sure
yeah I don't do creating that so like I
got games I'm good we would literally do
that [ __ ] not because we want people to
come to the show because people are
coming to show you the way yeah we just
did that just to let ladies know we're
coming through and it would just be the
easiest segue to have a conversation you
know so it's like oh you're coming
through they would DM you and we should
go to a bar let's kick it whatever and
that's how Don was hook up or that's how
we would talk to him and it was dope you
know it was just like an easy thing to
do but now before I was with it yeah
your face just got tighter
so the last time we went boxing right
the [ __ ] up because he's on a single
[ __ ]
I forgot guys do this [ __ ] so we're all
talking talking about boxing whatever
what not right having a great
conversation shorty calls him up on the
phone and all of a sudden he's like hey
what's up mama
he is the type that uses
like if he has a microphone
it would sound so uncomfortable hey Mama
it sounds uncomfortable to me I've never
seen somebody's tone change so fast
I'm a homie right now real quick yeah
I really like that though and I've never
really seen somebody do it so well
because I don't my My Talking flirting
voices are same as my regular voice yeah
I mean I don't know they're precious
when you see something precious you talk
to like Precious to them like
do you like that when a guy talks and
smooth on the phone for a second I
thought you were just gonna say do I
like it when a guy talks
smooth do that do the voice
is Robin with the fat ass
how you doing
I'm sorry oh my God
does that work Robin I mean I like I
wouldn't like just panty drop right
immediately but it's not it's
interesting okay I want you to do okay
let's say you guys are like lightweight
talking you met at a bar but you guys
just exchanged numbers right you call
Robin oh Robin you call Chris and then
you pick up pick up the phone he already
went yeah
yeah yeah
you did on the other day yeah ring ring
ring yo yo what up what up how you
feeling yeah that'd be nice
that's what we might as well yeah see
Rob is super easy that's all it took
it
outside
yeah
I don't feel the voice that often but uh
a sexy voice is nice oh oh I do you do
actually have a sexy voice so I agree oh
here we go
you sound real good actually you know
yeah
yeah
that [ __ ] look nice
so like for voice etiquette that really
matters to a girl then like so if you
pick up a phone and it's my voice and
I'm like hey what you doing yeah yeah
I'm [ __ ] then bro I really recognize
that actually the homies are the ones
that tell me that that it changes
because even the voice that he's using
right now Robin is nowhere near the
actual voice that he was you it was way
lower it was way slower and way sexier
it's like a Kryptonite to girls with
problems
you know what I'm saying girls with
problems and it's just daddy she's like
oh my God you guys
like yeah what's going on are you okay
are you okay yeah you respect me yeah
that voice is wild actually when she
said her name was Robin I thought that
was super I've never met a girl named
Robin I would love to be the Batman of
that
[Applause]
uh girlfriend and I just met her next
summer but I'm sure she's gotten this so
many times but you just do it just to go
like I know you've heard that I know
it'll still work because where she said
her name's summer I'm like oh my gosh I
just missed you you know because it's
now we're in Fall you know
you've gotten that I know you have I
know it's annoying but I just had two
slow hanging fruit and then just wow now
we're in conversation already yeah I
don't have that I'm always a girl want
to let you hit it
like get the [ __ ] out of here
you have a girl now yeah I got a girl
now okay I used to be out here okay well
she well she got into a car accident she
died
you [ __ ] reading my fantasies
if you were to meet a girl named summer
how would you hit on it summer yeah I'm
like oh my God I love that name I'll
just go out to her me I'm very like oh
[ __ ] how you doing
okay okay you know depending on body
language body language
[Laughter]
there's crazy people here
I know you're crazy people
want to go to Lowe's
when she gets uncomfortable you just
gotta turn games like I like the Fabrics
like a spitting game I don't like the
game I've always been just like I just
look in the eyes and then if you look
away and they look again it's because oh
you saw something you like so then I'm
like okay so what you looking at and
then I look at them and this is the most
pimping [ __ ] that I ever do is my move
when I'm at the bar cause loud or a club
and look at them we're locking icy
Smiles waves and I'm just man just go
come here like it's a little the phone
let me get your number like that like
okay come here and then she's like oh
yeah yeah boom we get the number what's
up where you been and I'm I always do
this whole thing like the club is the
worst place to hit on girls at the club
they're with their girls and be like hey
I know with your girls and everything
but I'm just I really like you I'm
feeling I want to get to know you let me
know let me send you a text later we can
hang out sometime this week all right
cool go be with your friends go do your
thing yeah and they're going and that's
it and then she still wants more she'll
come approach me yeah
Robin what's your sign
the Pisces oh my gosh
I'm a Cancer and no that's also a water
so you see but the thing is
hold up hold up hold up first of all
it's like a it's a show for him it's a
show oh my yeah
oh my god wow this one starts dancing
because in any sign every side you can
go down there oh they're wild oh I heard
about five years
what's your size she goes Pisces idiot
and I just walk away
get the [ __ ] off me like you're like all
right
yeah I needed some water something at a
young age bro my pops my pops was always
my dad or my older cousins it was always
a uh uh uh you like her go go go talk to
her go talk to her send off like my dad
was always like yo talk to go talk to
her go talk to her go talk to or you
can't get a number you can't get a
number you know that was what that was
what it was fun yeah
side [ __ ] for sure
there's a lot of trouble with that yeah
but yeah but uh but yeah so you know
that's that's pretty much like a lot of
L's it's not like I like every grab
approach has been like oh you got to
take a bunches like Stand Up You Gotta
bomb a couple times well that's the
thing too when I always tell young kids
like oh when people tell these stories
especially as guys we're only telling
the success Parts there's a [ __ ] ton of
elves it's it's the L's that kind of
toughens you up for the wins you know
what not to do so what's like your most
like memorable L that you're like I
can't believe that was the most
embarrassing there's like 3 000 of them
what's the one that haunts you that
you're just like oh my God
so this is one thing I [ __ ] remember
because I didn't know how to dance at
all because like you know I grew up at a
church so the only type of dancing we
would do we just prayers in the Lord
with our hands up so I just never danced
right and I didn't know how bad I was at
dancing and those girls that was really
cute
and literally I just went to dance with
her she just did not like she was like
Ugh and just walked away and I was like
okay I'm going to kill myself
and I'll tell my buddy he's like dog you
can't dance I was like okay so uh hold
on this whole time you just be I've been
making a fool of myself and you didn't
tell them what because it was funny
and so I was like okay I didn't know
this [ __ ] so I gotta learn how to
[ __ ] dance and then you know home
girls would you know give me a few tips
some of the fellas I'm like thank you I
just need the basics at least yeah and
that [ __ ] almost killed me because I
wanted to die somebody didn't want to be
around me because I couldn't dance
oh did you go home that night and like
money
it's on YouTube like how to yeah
and just try to see what everybody else
was doing and then just get better and
better like that you couldn't get better
at home like there was nothing to look
at you just had to figure it out as you
go we're gonna get rolled up for the
first time what's up getting rolled up
like a girl like like like oh yeah yeah
like twerking you know what I'm saying
like grinding on you I had to go to the
bathroom real quick this is a public
pool
I was pushing my [ __ ] back because I was
getting hurt I was like oh my God yeah
man I remember I had a girl like just
hitting on like hitting on me and I'm
like oh she was bad but she had her
cholo boyfriend uh-oh and it was one of
those girls that they're fighting she's
trying to make him jealous
and I'm over here just like but I'm here
like oh man yeah maybe my boys
she's all on me and she's just like and
I'm noticing this guy's all mad and I'm
just kind of like I'm in my I'm in my
zone and this guy's getting heated and I
just see him just come up to me and just
like start pushing me and then his
homies came up and I'm like what
happened what the [ __ ] and it was this
is why even got mad
I had a lot of those like at the bars
that's why I don't even go to the club
that's my club I get traumatized I'm
like yeah I was never like you know one
thing about me too is like the photos
real quick oh I got some photos real
quick but continue okay good oh dear I'm
now I'm nervous about these [ __ ]
photos
let's just go to a photo right now
lovely genius farts this podcast is
brought to you by betterhelp online
therapy my lovely friends have I talked
about Better Health of course I have
because I love better help because with
better help it means that I become a
better version of me with my online
therapist helping me navigate the
complicated the paths and wires of life
it's so complicated trust me and I know
it feels like sometimes I um even though
I speak well on the podcast and I say my
opinions and thoughts listen I don't
know everything duh I'm not the smartest
person on earth nor am I very well put
together and that's why where my
therapist comes in it's okay to feel
like that sometimes I think a lot of the
times we don't allow ourselves to feel
because we feel that if we talk to a
therapist that something is wrong with
this there's nothing wrong with you life
is just complicated and you need that
person to help guide you and that's
where my online therapist comes in
Better Health has been around for me for
many years and it can be there for you
as well you can learn coping skills a
self-empowerment dealing with trauma and
there's so many other things that I've
benefited from therapy as the world's
largest therapy service better help us
Mass 3 million people with
professionally licensed embedded
therapists available 100 online plus
it's super affordable so just fill out a
brief questionnaire to match with the
therapist if things aren't clicking you
can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime and it couldn't be simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapists learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
genius once again that is better
help.help.com
genius
it's all Rob is doing what the hell is
this what the hell okay all right
I got something to say
put it up put it up
hey who the [ __ ] is that make it oh let
me tell you something
he charged me 60 [ __ ] dollars
let me tell you something right now
your boy your boy
I'm sweet with them
make me look good I'm gonna let you look
delicious
in that Camaro that's out in that
parking lot he it was like newer at the
time he's like hey let me get some
pictures on my Camaro for the listeners
this is premises I'm bringing up photos
right now that Alex has of Jesus that
Alex did a professional photo shoot for
2014 professional Cemetery
back
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
with your hand real quick
[Music]
yeah for real dude there's a picture of
me and him Zeus in there somewhere uh
one of those Latin comedy jams hold on
hold on oh listen look at these other oh
these are great those this was my tender
profile pick for the longest dog right
there
see there was like 30 pictures
there's at least one good one look at my
face it looked like I do construction
[Laughter]
that was in uh Las Cruces oh yeah that's
right dude the big Hispanic comic I
forget his name uh why are you holding
your beers like that
awkwardness
you better just beat him by three feet
yeah for sure dude
because I was only 19.
Red's beard though yeah dude yeah Red's
beer that's what
when you look at yourself right here and
then you see how far you come now well
yeah well now right now I don't I don't
have time to like stop and look but
right now I'm like damn that's crazy
that was a long time
from that show I think I'm sure it's on
YouTube somewhere when we first met him
at John Levitz because I still remember
afterwards like him uh and afterwards
that gaudy guy was like he had me and
Patrick write down on papers like who we
thought we were the best right we all
put him first not just because he's here
right we all put Jesus but that's when
he brought Lee was like all right we're
gonna We Like Jesus that's why we came
down so that's why we want to try to
bring him on the you know was a and that
tour was like a big like highlight of my
career at the time because I was like
I'm gonna start getting paid yeah but
they didn't pay I thought I was gonna
get paid but I I came I'm always I
always had that look I always come in
when the money's gone everybody else was
getting money everybody was torrent or
the money was there but when I came in
it's like the low the shows were getting
lower and lower and they're like yeah we
were doing a thousand dollars now we're
just doing a hundred yeah
yesterday because I used to edit these
videos for him he had me edit this
commercial that's the truth and he lived
far as [ __ ] for me he lived like all the
way in like Queen Creek I live in South
Phoenix I drove all the way over there
to give them the the all the footage and
finalize and everything like that he's
like all right say a number
I was like all right 10 or whatever I
think it was 10. because the yeah I
think you paid me like 20 bucks he's all
right whatever you said I was gonna time
to buy two all right that's 12 million
yeah yeah right I was like damn you
can't just like give me a good amount
for editing you're gonna give me a Range
you said give me a number you're like
a number from what you know but I would
say this dude I would say this uh for
people that are watching like you know
it was a trip especially coming in here
trying to do entertainment you never
know who people are going to be at yeah
because look at this dude he's right
here he he was grinding on his own he
did his own thing he got to where he's
at where he's yeah you guys hanging out
with you guys yeah I did my thing with
the stand up so it's like you never know
you would have never thought that kid
was gonna be here or I was gonna we were
gonna meet again doing this [ __ ] like we
never gave up on what we were doing you
know so that's cool I met people in this
entertainment business like even [ __ ]
it's also when we started going he
started doing stand-up a little bit and
then yeah [ __ ] the next thing you
know like he's doing his own thing in
his own studio in Houston so it's like
you never know where people are creepy
that's what I'm saying
as I was asking you when you look at
these photos because I don't think a lot
of the times like when you work so hard
and you have your head down you don't
take a second to kind of appreciate all
the hard work you've done right right
there's a lot of people who probably
started out just like you but they
didn't put the the work or the effort
didn't make the leap and they're kind of
at the same place that they were before
like you took the lead you moved here
you were crying in a [ __ ] couch
jacket
lubricating with my tears
there's people right now in office jobs
hearing these that's podcasting going
like man like they're at a place where
they they have this dream but they're
too afraid to do it the difference
between you and me was I just took a
risk yeah that's it I'm not smarter I'm
not better I just took a risk yeah of
saying you know what
this might not work out but [ __ ] it I'd
rather try knowing that I tried than not
and then and you survived every hard
moment bro
you know like every time there'll be
times where you're just like man [ __ ]
this let's just get a [ __ ] real nine
to five and get a 401k in just a second
I had a good job at Coca-Cola and I quit
it I quit that cool you almost got me a
job there you told me about it too right
I was making money I was making like you
know the money I'm supposed to be making
like I could you know get my own place
and have my car but then I'm like and
then what I'm gonna be stuck here yeah I
need to just force myself to make money
doing what I have to do yeah and then
once you're starving literally starving
you'll find a way to make ends meet
doing what you love do you find that now
that you're a lot more successful do you
feel like sometimes like you're does
your grind ever like kind of disappear
sometimes where you get a little too
comfortable no because I don't have a
studio like you do
yeah
once I walked in I'm like oh I gotta
stay my game up
that's what we're doing we got any new
logos and [ __ ] okay
you got Robin coming out of nowhere I'm
like okay
I need a white girl
no but uh no I just it the the grind
doesn't stop I just like
um I still wanna I still want more like
because this is fun and the end of the
day this is fun fun for us yeah we love
doing this I always say too man like
there's always people who I see just
complain so much online I'm talking
about people who are in my space like
YouTube or whatever it's like oh this is
so hard you know it's not yeah like you
get to [ __ ] around and make money right
like the I for them like they're so
tunnel vision in this like privilege
that they've had this whole time right
so you realize like some of these kids
like it's like dude you [ __ ] pop
balloons and uh on your channel for 20
minutes and you get a [ __ ] Ten
Thousand Dollar Tree yeah
challenges and it's like bro I had to
wake up at five in the morning to go do
construction on my uncles and I didn't
even know nothing about construction I
almost killed myself in the [ __ ] roof
by Falling yeah but you're right it's
just like these guys don't know that
lifestyle they just know this so they
complain about what they know yeah
they're like oh I need a mental break
from your mental break
this is like a mental breakdown and I'm
not trying to minimize you know how you
feel you know what I'm saying I'm not
being dismissive of it but then like
perspective does help a lot a lot of
people don't want to hear perspective
because they think that you're being
dismissive of their current emotions
they go well this is how I feel so I
understand but perspective also helps
you kind of rationalize things a lot
right yeah because when people say stuff
like oh oh like I know I had to I dm'd
like one of my friends too he goes yeah
I'm having a tough time I said why are
you having a tough time right because I
know where he came from right I know how
[ __ ] [ __ ] his life was and he was
like yeah like
um like the shows are not paying as much
as they used to blah blah I was like dog
you're balling the [ __ ] are you
complaining about yourself like you have
a hell of money I'm like so the problem
isn't that life is hard for you it's
like you have shitty spending habits
because now that you make money you're
buying stupid Rolexes you still you're
still buying stupid [ __ ] right you know
what I mean so it's not meaningful yeah
I was like I remember like you were
living out of your [ __ ] car bro so
life is not that bad just like chill out
and you know for him because we're
friends he goes you're right man I'm
just [ __ ] being a baby about this
[ __ ] I was like yeah take take a day or
two off but you're you're complaining to
a bunch of people who follow you who
live a worse life than you telling these
kids who don't have what you have that
your life is harder than that yeah how
obnoxious is that [ __ ] that's stupid
plus I guarantee you like the way you I
bet you like I don't know how you grow
but I bet your parents put that in you
like no 100 there's no there's no room
for complaining here yeah like you know
what I mean like once you start
complaining they're like I don't want to
hear that [ __ ] like they'll give you a a
word a story that's going to be worth
complaining about and you just feel dumb
you're like yeah I can't believe I'm
complainable yeah you know we all go
through those like emotional shifts we
get like creative ruts and all that
other stuff but then I understand that
this is just a moment in time and I
learn to compartmentalize it and I don't
let I'm not trying to grab pity from
everybody that I see you know it's like
oh do you know how hard my day was do
you know how hard my day was right it's
like I have people that I talk to like
that which is like my wife we could talk
about [ __ ] oh yeah but I think like when
sometimes when you kind of get in your
own Zone and you think your life is the
worst it's it's when you're already
defeated right you know especially for
people who have it good I'm not talking
about people who have a rough I'm
telling this guy has it real good yeah
you know and he knew it too that's why
he was like yeah I'm being [ __ ]
stupid I was like yeah stop making
content for a couple days and just go
walk around have fun and then come back
to this yeah dude you know like this job
is like super fun it shouldn't be you
shouldn't be forcing yourself to be
stressed out and [ __ ] yeah are you first
generation uh yeah so I immigrated here
so I'm in first generation yeah no [ __ ]
yeah so you know it's different like my
first language was Korean I couldn't
even speak English when I came here oh
so like the whole perspective of me is
that you know I think when you just grow
poor like your your parents do a really
good job of making you feel like you
have more than enough yeah I do even
though you don't have [ __ ] yeah dude so
like because because they didn't have
yeah you know it's a trip too I'm always
like I always trip out on like the first
Generations it's like our parents like
we were brought here right but then we
are the generation how to figure it out
and I wanted to figure it out I mean
like learn about the American culture
it's like they did and they were just
working working that's all they know and
paying bills but we were learning how to
talk learning how to conversate with
people yeah I mean we were trying to
figure out how this thing and it took us
I took me at least getting out of high
school to kind of be like oh I think I
know what how this world works I think I
understand how to be around white people
which is weird but I can see where I fit
in because it I didn't know that until I
got out of high school and I started
getting my own like work and job and I
started I'm like oh I see where I see
how I can come in here I see how to be
around I see how to talk well that's the
hard part too like I think like
sometimes when people talk about uh
what's that like privilege or something
right and I'm not saying like in a bad
way like if your parents came here a few
Generations before of course you're
gonna have a leg up that's not a problem
that's [ __ ] dope like I respect that
but the idea of it is that people don't
understand how much of an advantage you
have when you just like a couple of
generations before your parents were
here because my parents didn't know
about scholarships my parents didn't
know how the system worked so we had to
figure it out as [ __ ] 12 13 year olds
yeah that's the hard part yeah we don't
know about this stuff we don't they
don't have people in their Community
telling them like oh you could apply for
this scholarship you can get a grant
here you can do this we don't know the
benefits yeah we don't know any of it we
don't know
because we don't think that we deserve
it it's me yeah I didn't I feel like I
thought that was just for them but I
realized like no I'm a mayor I was born
here I'm a citizen I deserve this too
yeah like I deserve the same rights to
you but we don't think we do because our
parents act like they don't I guess they
didn't because they weren't citizen but
they brought that into my upbringing and
I just felt like oh that's probably me
too I probably don't you know
we don't get that that's for them
because that's what he would say is like
hey is for the white people white people
I would always say that remember I will
go to like hey can we go to the movies
the theaters because I've never been and
he was like I asked for white people so
I thought
um
you know but he was anything that had to
do with like class or fanciness he would
always say that's for wiping as white
people and then a lot of people do and I
grew up thinking that I didn't deserve
this because it's for them not knowing
that it's like [ __ ] like
[ __ ]
mentality though and you're right a
couple because a couple of generations
back like I I like third generation
Latinos they're a little different they
they got it figured out yeah man and I
that's why I like Our Generations are so
different in how we view life like the
the level of complaint Now is really
really high I'm pretty sure the
generation before us did the same thing
about us too but now it's like
especially because I'm in a position of
of like I've hired people casted people
for things there's a lot of idea of like
I deserve this just because there's no
just because you have to earn your way
especially like in entertainment you
know whether whether it's you know you
smoothing or talking to the right people
you still have to earn your way through
here right and a lot of the times people
get upset at other people because they
don't have what they have when they
didn't do [ __ ] to get it it's like you
can't complain you don't have what I
have like I'll give you a great example
like
there was a dude in Sacramento we
started doing stand-up together he was a
trash stand up right
he was trash
dude this guy was [ __ ] hot hot trash
and I mean like [ __ ] flaming trash
[Music]
[ __ ] waiting in line five o'clock
at 6 p.m tonight laugh at him and throw
tomatoes yeah but
when I uh started blowing up on YouTube
right I actually was trying to put him
on you know for stand-up and stuff but
his stand-up wasn't good uh he would do
like small dick Asian jokes and then you
know it's like Jesus Christ man like
nobody [ __ ] cares about this yeah and
his sets were so [ __ ] bad
um I moved to LA and there was a couple
of dudes that I was trying to you know
me I'm always trying to put people on
all the time because I like that it
actually makes me feel good to watch
people succeed because even when some
some of my friends like start doing in
my mind better than me it motivates me
to catch up to them and I like this
energy it feels good so I want to be
around people who work really hard
that's why I put on anybody that I
believe on it believe in it doesn't
[ __ ] matter so I would do the same
for them but they didn't want to do the
work yeah so when I left to la lo and
behold like I get a message years later
from Facebook he goes hey bro I just
want to let you know I'm still doing
stand up and I'm like all right
and he writes to me he goes I just want
to let you know like it was my birthday
he goes happy birthday but you know you
left to LA and I've kind of held this
like in my heart I didn't want to tell
you this but you know I felt it was kind
of [ __ ] up that you didn't take me
with you and I'm like on your birthday
wait one more day yeah
I was like okay number one I didn't know
that uh I owned you I know you're my
property I know you're a luggage yeah
you know but he felt a certain way
because I started making a name for
myself but I was working really really
hard I was like listen if you wanted to
come to La you should have just came to
that yeah you know what I mean like I
came here broke as [ __ ] yes like [ __ ]
bored dog I had this desk and I had a
computer that I got so I you know I was
working a part-time job or whatever so I
sold everything that I had just to buy
this computer so I could edit videos and
then I stayed here and I remember like
the First YouTube check I got was two
months later and I was just living off
of this like a few hundred bucks that I
had and my cousin let me live at the
place and he covered my rent for the
first couple months until I got my first
paycheck wow and it was hard dude eating
Top Ramen every day it's like dog you
didn't get to have that struggle yeah
but now you're upset at me oh yeah but
you weren't there like when I was like
oh [ __ ] do I have enough money for
[ __ ] to get this Gatorade yeah you
know this [ __ ] bottle of water I
don't I don't have money
and so this dude he writes he goes I
just want to let you know that I think
that you're more successfully but you're
not a better comic than me and I'm like
there it was he goes happy birthday
and so I was pissed and I wrote back to
him the same thing I said I was like
you're not I don't owe you anything
number two if you were funny you would
have made it I was like the problem is
you're not funny and you're not talented
so don't get mad at me because you were
never a funny comic in the first place
yeah if you would have worked hard maybe
you would have been and he just kind of
like didn't write back yeah right and
I'm like because it's true because now
he's not doing it at all yeah now he
killed himself
[Laughter]
he went out of his way to make me feel
like [ __ ] even though I went out of my
way to kind of like come up with him he
didn't want to do the extra work yeah
and so he was going around town you know
talking [ __ ] about me but I was over
here in L.A saying great things about
him yeah and at that point I was like oh
this is two different mentalities right
right because I was like hey this dude
like I used to work with him you know I
hope he's still doing stand-up if he
comes up here I'ma put him on and this
is what I was saying to him to other
people and then lo and behold I hear on
the other side he was saying I'm a piece
of [ __ ] that I'm I backstabbed him I was
like there was nothing to do
you forgot about you yeah I don't even
know you existed
I was like oh it's [ __ ] he's still alive
the idea that he messaged me out of his
way to say like I'm a better comic than
you I was like number one like bro I do
YouTube videos now yeah you know I mean
like I'm in a different Lane I'm trying
to make film I'm doing a little thing
too so you should do us and I he's still
doing stand-up today and I asked my
friend did he get any better he goes
dude he bombs still till this day yeah
yeah you know Comics are so insecure bro
right it's so insecure like and they say
[ __ ] like that I've been in a position
like especially when the special drop
like I got those messages too no way bro
dude because people like why why would
you do that because you're a reflection
of their failure dude you're just like
oh [ __ ] I could have done this if I did
try like you did but they were afraid to
do it but we did it yeah and now they
expect us to like just bring them on
it's like bro like
you can't I can't give this to you you
got to earn this [ __ ] yeah if you didn't
give it to them they wouldn't they
wouldn't know what to do with it yeah
it'd be all right right now let's say
that guy you give him a spot you give
them a chance you put them on the
[ __ ] mic he's not gonna do anything
with this opportunity he's just gonna be
frozen bomb and it's like bro like
that's out of your hands yo I'll give
you a great example too I didn't put
these podcasts up so there's a couple of
podcasts a few that I don't put on just
because I there's a couple of things I
think about it's like number one hope
this one goes up
[Laughter]
but I had a comic buddy come on and he's
he's been doing it for a while right and
listen he's funny but he hasn't made a
new set in [ __ ] 10 years yeah you got
those guys yeah exactly right and so he
comes on the podcast and he's just kind
of griping about like other comics about
making excuses why he didn't make it and
I'm like dog nobody wants to hear this
on a podcast nobody wants to hear about
you [ __ ] on other comments a Debbie
Downer yeah exactly nobody wants to hear
about why you you couldn't do things
because of this because of your family
because you have kids I was like at the
end of the day dude this was an
opportunity for you to come on here and
do something and you [ __ ] blew it
again yeah yeah like you're so negative
like you came on here just to talk about
how sorry you are right you're not funny
anymore
you know what I I like like those type
of talks like when I have people around
me that talk and be real like hey what
are you doing it's the same [ __ ] yeah
some other Comics they get they shut
down they break down they get emotional
I need that I grew up with that well I
grew up with my dad telling me like hey
you're [ __ ] up you know yeah so I
need that around I don't know how to
handle that you know I would say that uh
like I've done shows with Jesus I've
done a lot of shows with them and I've
he's been you know generous enough to
have me feature a feature for him too
and uh he'll he'll let me know too he'll
tell me straight up you know we'll go
we'll go on walks he likes to go on
walks before he shows he watches yeah
let's go for it let's go first
and he knows what it is you know saying
like I he knows I got the child support
he also knows like yo like if you feel
really about it if you really want to be
in this game bro you're gonna have to
step it up you know what I'm saying and
uh because I remember I mentioned
something of like bro I can't wait to
get on like do my tour you know and then
when I do I mean like you feature for me
he said
he was saying like I'm just like yeah I
like that he and Chris has that Chris
has that like energy was just like he's
very confident and then and sometimes I
tell him like yo yo yo yo yo yo player
calm the [ __ ] down on your breaks yeah
because to me was like I saw what you
were doing up there and it's like
you know what I mean you're not ready
for that position I know you feel like
you are but you're not like uh what I'm
doing up there is like I'm freestyling
and I'm really trying to pull I'm the
headliner you
you can bomb if you want like and it's
okay you're the future I gotta bring it
yeah it's like I gotta I have that
pressure of the show the show is me I
gotta bring it and it's like bro like
you're not there yet but you will be but
you're not there yet for him to say
that's what I was trying to tell him
like yo and I told him like perfect
examples you know what if you think
you're there all right then tonight yeah
every minute needs to be like boom boom
boom boom then I'll be like you got it
he goes up there hi everybody
[Laughter]
exactly yeah
yeah
but you know uh I was still happy to be
a part of that show bro that was cool
because yes that was the conversation we
had beforehand right and he's like okay
tonight like like show me like you you
got it bro 30 boom back to back last
whatever every minute I remember that
[ __ ] I was like all right back come on
you know and uh and then it wasn't like
crowd right but but it was also like
what what does it matter because you
still you still handle that that crowd
like you know I mean
yeah it was a light crowd and so and so
but uh I remember I'm I'm on stage and
like yeah I'm doing a couple crowd
workout and I'm working in I'm just kind
of and but it is it's like it's not it's
not anything bro I'm not hitting you
know I mean and I just remember like
look at I'm I'm looking in his Direction
and he's just right there like yeah yeah
I had my little dragon
pinky up and everything
yeah I told you yeah
I would say it is cool to see because
like you guys talking about it from the
perspective like with Comics right going
up but like for me I've got to see Jesus
for like over like almost 10 years now
yeah so to me it's kind of cool because
he's probably like the first comic that
I've seen because my boy Patrick does
comedy but he's kind of just slowed down
now right he doesn't show here and there
but Jesus is like the first comic I've
got to see where he was doing like the
first or second spot on these tours when
we're going around 10 minutes five
minutes whatever like that doing little
sets and when I first moved here him uh
his friend Jerry all those people
they're the only people I knew so like I
used to go to the The Ice House to see
them perform and it was like little sets
but now it's like he's like the
headliner and he's like yeah yeah yeah
you know so it's cool to see from the
outside perspective because it was a
long ground you always hear these Comics
be like oh [ __ ] yeah I've been doing
this for like 15 years and you're just
like damn it's a long time but then I've
got to witness it I'm like yeah this is
cool
with him as a homie because like my
first feature weekend I'm excited is the
new thing and for hearing him to say
like yo you can open up for me I'm like
you know how long it took me to get here
like a homie thing because I had
somebody do that to me yeah I had a guy
uh the guy that I when I was on the road
with I told him like I'm ready to
headline is up so all right I'm Gonna
Bump you from your 10 minutes to do your
20 minutes and then let's see what's up
yeah it's like and then and I'm gonna go
in between so you're gonna have to
follow me and I'm like who which
headliner does that he was gonna just do
his first 15 minutes instead of from a
60 just to see how it feels and that was
just hot like 15 minutes and I'm like
yeah I got it so I'm a headliner so you
think you're better than me he put me on
the spot and that's when I humble myself
and said oh I got work today
around you because like you know I've
talked about on this podcast where you
know Brenda shops uh specials both of
them were really really bad yeah and
I've openly said it's like really really
bad you know I never I never met that
guy but look when I met him this is
really cool I think like his off camera
Persona is so much funnier than his
on-camera Persona right and so like I
always and I said on the previous
podcast where I was like yo who the [ __ ]
is in a circle because if somebody was
really cared about him they would said
like hey some of these jokes are funny
but you're not ready for the special yet
so let me help you work this that was
what I was gonna get at yeah
I I mean he's a smart guy I would if I
would him I would wait a little bit keep
creating podcast content you're not
going anywhere like you're making money
you're cool but the stand-up is like
this is an art form bro like you're
making it more of like uh this is I
could do it this is not that yeah this
doesn't take just like oh I'll just go
out there and do it because he was
saying that oh like he he grinds out
he's working on these jokes it's like no
matter how much you grind yeah you got
ears you gotta [ __ ] refine this [ __ ]
and like I feel like some of his jokes
like oh that could have been funny but
that shouldn't have been in your special
like you could have taken a step back
refined it or who the [ __ ] is in your
circle why aren't they telling you this
like yo yeah bro that [ __ ] wasn't
hitting like that's the see that's the
thing because I have homies who would
who would hear the same thing I would
say and go oh damn that'd be tight bro
oh you're gonna be killing yourself it
would have his homies like Jesus who who
have done the work and know and be like
hey bro as a homie I'm gonna tell you
right now bro enjoy the feature spot
enjoy that that was the coolest thing
that you said bro you were like you were
like bro so much less pressure yeah
and learn from this world right here
yeah enjoy the the process of meeting
people after of people like saying I
like that bid I like that all this bid
was great and you're learning from that
bit and growing from that bit yeah and
like just have fun with not having to
deal with going to do radio having to
[ __ ] put more than six people in the
[ __ ] seats you
enjoy this you're trying to overstep and
it's like nah bro enjoy this process
because I know you know like he could
get with him he's he's funny he's got
the chops you know I pitch with it
it's funny
I mean I would do less dancing on stage
and more jokes
no but but you know I know he's ready
it's just like that was just a little
moment of like you know as a homie like
a yeah I think that's really cool of you
to do that too because it's not like
you're [ __ ] on him right no no and I
have that too where there's always
people in my circle that's just like hey
hey man what the [ __ ] yeah there's a
reason why I called him a feature
because I I think he's ready for that
spot I was like okay ready to feature
for sure yeah yeah you're ready to be up
there but yeah but we were talking about
too when he's on the previous podcast
like uh like his stand up your stand up
from [ __ ] a year for ago till now is
just very different like you have your
voice now you're a lot more comfortable
on stage and now it's like even some
people are so good at just I think like
being on stage like not everything is
funny but you still want to listen
because yeah
he has that like ability yeah that like
even if it's not really hitting the idea
was funny so they're gonna laugh at it
and then he's likable like you don't
come off too strong where you're like
man I think like that's the hardest part
because like uh like with the comics
that I have always watched or I really
enjoy It's just sometimes it's how
comfortable are they saying these jokes
right because sometimes I feel like
Comics they go it almost sounds like
you're waiting for the button bump yeah
rather than you just talking your [ __ ]
and you're a funny ass dude up there but
it's it's a set but you don't know it's
a set it just sounds like you're just
talking yeah I think that's why
Chappelle is so great yeah that's why
like Bill Burr is so great is because
they just sound like they're talking
[ __ ] but it's actually a set yeah
that's where you confuse the audience
and you know only a real comic knows
what he's doing yeah and so like you
know before this I watched all your
stuff I was like there's a difference
here you know especially when I was
doing stand when I was younger out I
look at my old clips I have like a bunch
of footage about I [ __ ] cringe and
I'm like dog you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're saying
that's the thing when I first came out
here like I wasn't I was never that
comic uh that was just going up there
like [ __ ] around and see what happens
I didn't have that luxury because uh I
did sacrifice coming over here I had no
family out here so like you know I mean
I was just I had to pay my bills I had
all this stress I was literally the
comic that was like ah through pain is
how I'm getting these jokes out like
through all this pain like of doing with
all this stress I go on stage and I'm
gonna let it out I'm gonna try to kill
because I'm not here to like see if this
joke works like no this gotta work
because I don't got nothing left you
know what I mean yeah I was that
different comedy I see some comments at
The Comedy Store and they're just all
gullible like oh yeah I was still on the
Dick joke and I'm like and they're just
I didn't work whatever that's not me bro
if it didn't work I'm in the car Why
didn't it work trying to figure out that
night I would stay up all [ __ ] night
because I was trying to kill every time
I was on I wasn't playing out here I
wasn't trying to be okay I'm trying to
kill okay so this is definitely one of
the uh one of the like few Comics that I
know that really put in that work for
real and he's really about he's not just
talking like this ain't just talk I've
been like I've been in your crib he's
been you know he'll be out of time like
bro you could stay in my room whatever
and I've seen this room bro he has it's
like a like a mad mad scientist bro like
he has like uh the the index cards and
like the the premise like all the
structure to his jokes he's really
putting it work bro and yeah something
that people don't see right and I think
that's the part that I always want
people to listen to because they go oh
he's talented yeah but the talent
doesn't mean [ __ ] if you don't work hard
yeah all these people who work hard like
nobody looks at Kobe and goes like he's
talented everybody said Kobe is the
hardest [ __ ] uh working person in the
room yeah and he even says that about
himself like he did it to the point
where his body broke down right you
never saw people do the work that he did
so that's like the biggest [ __ ] thing
there's a lot of there's a lot of comics
that have specials through connections
yeah I got it through that [ __ ]
material
because like I said right I've known him
for 10 years and I have a lot of friends
that are Comedians and I've been to a
[ __ ] ton of shows and I've seen people
have good sets I've seen people have bad
says I don't think not even busier I
don't think I've ever seen one bad set
and obviously and I'll be upstairs going
like damn yeah it's always been that one
I still even when I saw the special I
was like oh when it comes three things
that I wish I would have changed
what I'm saying like I don't know why
somebody like you know I'm not dragging
his name through the mud but I don't
know why Brendan can't say that openly
right he can't he won't verbally say it
I think that's why he gets a lot of [ __ ]
well that's why Comics are like talk
[ __ ] about it because it's like
especially Comics like like me like I
sacrificed my life for this yeah for you
to just go out there and just play
um yeah I take that as disrespect
because I'm like [ __ ] like but I
don't have to say anything your work
speaks for yourself I never met him I
never you know what I mean but I saw and
I was like there was no fear in my heart
going like oh I gotta watch my back I
was like oh that's cool he's whatever I
gotta keep going like I'm looking at
people like bro I'm looking at Chappelle
I'm trying to get to that you know I'm
trying to get to this you'll see
specials uh uh that have came out
because I mean now they're I mean you're
just seeing especially everything
everybody has specials right and and it
comes off that way it comes off as like
oh they're Boomer right now they got
they they book something so now their
name's big let's throw them a special
because they've done stand up so they
can do yeah
and
um it's it's so well crafted you can
like it it is a special you're watching
somebody on stage who is incredibly
talented put the work in and it's like
I've seen the set that I've seen you
craft your your jokes and stuff and so
when it when it's all put together
you're watching this like it's non-stop
laughter it's 30 minutes of just
straight like bangers and you're hitting
bro like it's it was so like I was
admiring it bro like yeah for real bro
it was so dope that's from watching you
know the Chappelle's and those guys that
made me laugh remember the guys that
made us laugh yeah
and that's the [ __ ] that I missed that
that's the comedy that I like that's why
I like I know a lot of people dislike
Aries Spears right but Aries Spears you
know he has some gems where he says
something very profound because he's
been doing stand-up since ever since he
was a team yeah uh Def Comedy Jam all
the other [ __ ] and he said like are you
a comic he goes are people are you out
there to kill on stage where somebody's
out there and they're literally belly
aching because they're laughing is a
little hard that's when you're when
you're a real comic that's what you're
looking for if you're up on stage and
you get a few Giggles here and there
it's like you're I think you're a funny
guy yeah but why do this you know like
dude yeah you [ __ ] you got it you
said it yeah so when he said that I'm
like I agree because you know when
people show me their they're like oh
this guy's kind of funny I was like well
don't show me somebody who's kind of
funny I don't want to see I want to cry
[ __ ] laughing dude yeah like and you
know comedy's very subjective but
sometimes when people show me Comics
they go oh my friend the stand up I'm
like oh cool let me and I go see him do
his [ __ ] I'm like dude you've been doing
this for like seven years but you suck
yeah you suck bad like people giggle
yeah but if if you walk off stage and
you go oh I had a great set I'm like
that wasn't a great set everybody just
chuckled like yeah don't you want people
to [ __ ] die laughing yeah yeah that's
how I am people get out that's how I
talk I tell these comments like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about I was out
there chill Are you
seriously like we'll be at the these
come out yeah I had a great set I'm like
what
I was there yeah are you serious I don't
really have the the guts to do it unless
like we're really cool but even then I'm
just like kind of too nice to still be
like are you sure bro cause I don't know
like I don't know I'm tough on myself
and it's just like when people just
compliment themselves I'm like it's a
first generation thing because you're
like your hardest critic right yeah so
yeah and no matter what we're gonna
always hyper focus on the one thing that
went wrong right so like for example so
uh buddy Jason Cheney stand in comedy
have a joke every time we see each other
he always tells me did you bring the
shovel because he says I always leave a
hole in the stage and it makes him hard
for him to work
he's always like oh he brought a shovel
huh about the shovel today and I tell
him the same thing I was like oh look at
you chasing this he's like one of those
dudes naturally funny like he's because
he's half [ __ ]
I see it too I see his eyes wandering
I'm like oh
I got him on the podcast and I you know
got him on JK news because I just wanted
him to be on there because people need
to see how [ __ ] funny he is I would
have never known I the first time I met
him was at that [ __ ] funny fight yeah
yeah and I had no idea he was swole as
[ __ ] yeah exactly ripped oh yeah
he was that funny yeah he's so [ __ ]
funny and I remember at that Boston he
goes he goes yeah I'm a big fan of yours
and I was like all right
I don't know where you're looking at
right now
I like you yeah
he comes from the same school I've seen
him at the mics that I was at
I've seen him grind he's been like when
I was coming up he's like he was with me
going through all these like shows
that's why both of you have that same
work ethic though you know you guys work
really hard and he's the one that's
trying to get me to do stand up again
he's he's on my [ __ ] ass every day
yeah but you got to tell me I don't know
why you're not you know it's just like I
kind of fell out of love with it so I
don't it's the same thing with you
if I do stand up I want to give it my
all and I don't want to half-ass it
because I love I think static is so
disrespected now yeah everybody's like
I'll just do stand-ups like all right
[ __ ] like it's just so disrespectful so
I don't want to be in that so next year
I want to try doing it but I got every
day I'm always running stand up all the
time because you know I've been doing
since I was 16. so if something's funny
I'll write it out I just don't perform
it yeah just in case but but I think you
know I think that you have an audience
that likes you figured it out the thing
about you is like this was difficult
about me I had to make the audience like
me you have an audience that likes you
yeah you can just cater to your audience
and just use your voice because I'm
gonna end up like when I do my shows I'm
catering to my audience anyways yeah you
don't have to like try to make them like
me you know yeah you're starting to do
shows for people that like me already so
you have that you can already know you
can do small rooms like 80 feet 80 feet
or stuff so figure out I definitely had
that moment so Jason we were at uh so I
was gonna go see him at uh harvell's out
in Long Beach oh yeah I go there I was
like okay cool I'll go see that I'm you
know I want to see you perform and work
out some of these jokes so I show up and
then Pat's with me too Pat's gonna
perform and then Pat starts laughing his
ass off I'm like what's up what are you
laughing at and he goes so you're
performing tonight and I'm like no the
[ __ ] time I'm just gonna go watch and
he goes That's funny because your face
is on like the Marquee I'm like wow what
the [ __ ] are you talking about stand up
in like six seven years oh wow and I'm
like no you [ __ ] around and I see
this text and Jason Goes you're gonna be
a [ __ ] and I walk up I literally grab
Jason I [ __ ] Muay Thai name in the
stomach
I love him so I'm angry but I can't stop
laughing because how funny this is so
like the comic inside you makes you want
to laugh
as soon as the fear comes down I'm
sweating my ass off and then Jason looks
at me he goes oh you for real don't want
to go up I'm like you follow that video
when did I tell you I wanted to yeah I
was like I literally told you I have
anxiety issues I'm dying right now
so Jason's like me too prepping me up
he's like dog this is [ __ ] go up
there like there's titties out here
everybody goes out here to work their
jokes just say whatever but in my mind
I'm like I don't even have a joke to say
yes but you see what Jason is doing
these are the the thing about me and
Jason we have that what's your dude that
that moment is not about trying to kill
it's just embracing the fear of bombing
yeah their fear is bombing yeah what
he's doing is like yeah face your fear
it was scary right you looked uncontrol
you know what happening all right get
over that yeah I don't know how that
feels now do it again it's gonna get a
little bit better and better and that
wasn't bad too because like I think when
I really took a step back I was like am
I so there's like two things that are
happening my anxiety and fear of bombing
and the other thing is I ain't no
[ __ ] [ __ ]
these two things are battling each other
all it took was one beer I smashed that
beer back I was like ain't no [ __ ]
[ __ ]
since I was 16. yeah so I'll go up and I
don't do bad right what's up man
[Laughter]
he grew up on the south side of his City
yeah
yeah so I go up and I don't do that bad
right and then Jason was like see you
[ __ ] people were like you were doing
really really well and I was like I
think the part that [ __ ] me up the
most is that I just didn't want to do
bad and I didn't want to go home and
think like oh I'm not funny like oh yeah
I'll beat you up I can only make people
laugh at people who know me but
strangers I can't make laughs because
I'm not an actually funny guy and I
think that was the fear that I had in my
head but then when I went up there and I
got [ __ ] laughs I was like oh [ __ ] I
am funny you know and it kind of
confirmed like okay those years of you
doing stuff still there it's [ __ ]
shitty it's Rusty but you could work up
to get back to where you were yeah
you're battling your mind bro yeah so
like I get the same thing but you come
on yeah you've been in the game you got
it like yeah so like that's the thing
too and then Chris always tells me to
stand up too and then yeah you
definitely you should be doing it yeah
you should be out here I mean next year
too is like I do want to do something
you know struggling to clubs and then I
just I want to get that feeling of
bombing just looking again yeah yeah you
get Jason on your on your side dude
that's a good guy to have around you
because he knows the game he's like and
I watched him too he's just up there
working jokes yeah he was like you put
too much pressure on yourself he goes go
up there take it seriously but work if
it doesn't work out then go back and fix
it just [ __ ] fix it you know and
that's the thing too is like I got so
nervous I didn't know what the [ __ ] I
was saying so I didn't know what was
hitting or not yeah did you guys record
it so I know the jokes he goes we don't
record it I'm like okay
[Laughter]
I love performing I love doing this uh I
love that feeling of like right now I'm
bombing a lot because I'm doing new
material so I'm just taking all those
L's right now trying to mold I just
gotta feel because there's new ideas
they're not ready and and it's it kind
of sucks because people are like they
announced yeah they're like he just
dropped an HBO special like [ __ ]
I'm working on you material yeah it's
like you don't say that you know that's
the rule but you get excited anyways but
I go out there and I'm just trying to
figure out and I got like another set
that I'm doing right now that's but yeah
I mean some days I have no idea I go out
there and I bomb and I'm like all right
that was weird next show let's [ __ ]
go I've been living with uh with the
with the bombs because of of my of the
studio in Houston because it was when I
when I pushed those shows I was I was
hosting them so
um
it's 50 seats and it's they're all right
there they're it's like every rose the
front row you know what I'm saying and
so yeah
there's no choice but to really just
like work through it you just gotta go
you know me and that and that's what
made me like stronger and more uh
comfortable with being in you know shows
that I could do at the hour or Laugh
Factory to have like big crowds and
they're already there to just have a
good time and just like okay I'm gonna
rock this because I've already I've
already yeah
when I did the special dude like people
don't know I went to New York to do it I
didn't film it in here oh in front of
Latinos it was in front of like a lot of
white people Puerto Rican Dominicans you
know but when I got there on Saturday
we're filming it on Thursday bro on
Saturday when I got there I invited my
mom my dad and my girlfriend right oh
[ __ ] I rented I brought them out with me
so they're with me first time in New
York we're excited and then they're like
are you ready we got a comedy club for
you so you can practice on material and
I'm like all right I've never been in a
New York crowd it's my first time
getting in my head a little bit and dude
these [ __ ] got cameras on me
like all right ready [ __ ] they got
the logo HP
all right dude just be normal and like
what the [ __ ] in New York crossing the
street they're following me around it's
all this pressure I'm just like bro like
[ __ ] let me breathe let me figure out
this scene this is my first time here
yeah I go to the Comedy Club right away
we're in the green room they got the
camera [ __ ] yeah my man like you know
what I mean and then the comics are like
hey what's going on what was all this
yeah
oh word word word okay okay that's
what's up yeah [ __ ] he says you're
about to go up everybody in the green
room is now out waiting to see whoa yeah
what's Coach Guy hey what's coach you
good West Coast
yeah yeah I'm definitely on West Coast
I'm nervous dude sweating dude I'm just
like and then they go up and they bring
me up and uh my dance right there in the
front the the cameras are all around
dude and I I just I just I'm so nervous
dude I bombed I just I freaked out I was
nervous yeah and I was just hey how's
everybody doing in the New York right
and people are just like what the [ __ ] I
look service I was uncomfortable the
stage is small I knew I did bad when the
cameras went all right
We're Gonna Save tape you know what I
mean and I'm just I bombed dude the
worst five minutes I got lit and I came
out and everybody in the back man I
already knew it was go ahead and got it
man that's why they gave these specials
to the whack women oh [ __ ] I'm hearing
this and I'm in my head and I'm like
[ __ ] yeah my dad is we're walking back
to the hotel my dad's like are you sure
you're gonna record me
you're sure you're gonna do a special
he's telling the producers I you don't
have to today
I mean next year if you're getting one
more year he's got it right now
he's yelling at me he's just [ __ ]
like hey they're paying for the hotel if
you don't do good they're gonna make me
pay
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so I'm like nervous and then
I'm in the hotel room and I'm like what
the [ __ ] is I'm doubting everything but
that's one of those moments where you're
just like oh I'm letting my emotions
overpower my intelligence I'm letting
that control my my head we have that a
lot of us have when we have fear it like
blocks us and we give up yeah and I'm
like no no I've been here before this is
why I did all these years this is why I
did all those bar gigs this is why I did
those gigs when they have a game on and
I have to fight to get the audience this
is what it prepared me for this moment
when fear hits you gotta work your way
out of it and I snapped out of after the
third night I got him I was like oh I'm
going too fast yeah take my slow it down
and I was back I was like oh what the
[ __ ] was wrong with me
so I snapped that out I was like oh come
on dude and I got it and after that it
was just on I was like ready to go and
then we filmed it first show boom just
got em they even said we got it we have
two shows we got them on the first one
the second one just play
man I was really just playing with them
and just I was having fun I remember we
did 40 I did 45 minutes on this on the
second one yeah but they took pieces out
and that's perfect yeah but yeah but you
know what I'm saying it's just one of
those things that when you doubt
yourself you got to remind yourself like
hey bro you this you've been here
that little moment of doubt I could have
easily just been like and let it control
me but you just gotta you know you gotta
remind yourself like you know this is
all these years of doing this this is
why it ain't amateur hours yeah that's
for sure yeah I [ __ ] love it man yeah
yeah well man uh that was a dope podcast
yeah
Jesus where can they find you uh and
Instagram Jesus the comedian uh she's
the comedian on Instagram anything else
you want a shout out uh just so I got
shows coming up so I have the link on my
Instagram to upcoming shows so follow
Jesus on his Instagram you can follow
Chris at Chris Sosa Christina
uh all doing stand up glad to go to the
show it's [ __ ] funniest yeah
yeah
every Sundays at 12 p.m we'll see y'all
next time peace
[Music]